paul we're curious what prompted you to
make
a road trip movie where you say on your
website four guys stuffed in a small van
with rolls of film
seeing where the road would take them
what prompted this sounds like quite a
good line actually who came out with
that
um um what prompted us to make this film
um basically curiosity at the time as to
how americans felt about america
and and really i was curious about that
because i didn't know how i felt about
america at that time
i was struggling i've always loved
america ever since i was a kid you know
and um at that time i was sort of
struggling with the economic downturn
and the way that this american dream had
sort of fallen in on itself and
the sort of hell-bent pursuit of
material goods consumption all these
things supposed to make you happy and i
was like well hang on this isn't
quite working is it it's just fallen
flat on its face that whole notion
and i wasn't too sure how i was feeling
about america but i thought before i
really formed an opinion i
should perhaps speak to more of the
people out of
out of america outside of the areas that
i spend most of my time i.e new york los
angeles east and west coast those areas
so i've sort of wanted to get into the
sort of the heartland of america and
speak to the people out there especially
the ones that gets
that those areas that get such a hard
you know they get a lot of rap about oh
you know just fly over country and bible
belt and
you know rust belt and stuff like no
there's something going on there i want
to speak to these people
and so i felt if i spoke to those people
the main the people at the heart of
america
i'd be able to form a better opinion how
i felt about america at that time
so that's what i did we just got on the
road and um with those rolls of film and
and drove across america and interviewed
lots of very interesting characters
well did you have it in your mind for a
little bit like oh you know
i'd like to do this and then you kind of
wrestled with it and then you said no
i'm making this
no okay well i'll answer both those okay
so after the economic downturn
i was very curious particularly um about
the uh
the the how americans were feeling about
the country and as i said the pursuit of
the american dream
um so that's pretty much it was after
that downturn that i decided
like let's you know i want to go and
speak to the people of america
and um it was all done on a bit of a
whim really
uh because i had this sort of whimsical
notion yeah i drive across america and i
need to view people and that's going to
be easy isn't it
and in hindsight that kind of was the
easiest bit um
it's the actually putting the film
together afterwards which is the really
challenging bit the the drive across
america
which we did over a period of a month
was uh that was the easy
bit that was enjoyable and pleasant a
road trip across america hey you know
it's lots of fun
um and so i had this at a whimsical
notion that this would be a great idea
um i just moved back into i recently
moved back into a neighborhood in
brooklyn i hadn't lived in for a long
time and i got to know this australian
guy that ran this cafe called smooch in
in fort greene in brooklyn
and um and i was just sort of getting to
know this guy i knew for about a month
and i said i'm thinking about driving
across america and interviewing people
he went well i'll come with you mate
i was like um don't know you very well
but i don't know we've been hanging out
and he was kind of feeling the same
we've been in america for a similar
amount of time as i had
so i thought well you know only live
once
and uh so um it was literally about two
weeks later
we were on the road and um doing it
so it was a very short period of time
between the
inception idea inception some aussie guy
saying i'll come with you
and being on the road with an old
cameraman friend of mine a sound friend
of mine
and this stuffed in this van rolls a
film and seeing where the road took us
you know so yeah that was that and the
romance of it never wore
off within that month the bromance still
continues no we're best of mates we
actually made it through this uh
the whole experience not just the trip
itself but the making of the film itself
which as i said that's the really
challenging bit
sure no um we're very uh very very good
friends and um
yeah it's been great it's been a great
experience it's been one of those things
where you think oh yeah why not and then
you're suddenly like oh wow glad i did
that
you know what did uh the making of this
american journey teach you about people
you know you're dealing with the
heartland yeah versus new york and l.a
which you're so used to
well what the film taught us well i
taught us things on uh
many things on many levels but i think
one of the main things that you know
is born out watching the film is the
you know how how quickly we are to judge
people uh based on their appearance
and their location well i'm here and
here they're talking like that and
they're dressed like that so
i bet we're going to get a bit of this
you know but if you actually sit down
you know spend a little moment talking
listening to people
it's amazing what you'll actually find
and it's not that far
you know beneath the surface and yet
obviously for the sake of
a lot of people who like to divide label
and divide people so that people can
obviously be controlled a bit more
easily
manipulated more easily you know a lot
of this
sort of divisiveness and labeling is
encouraged
and what we discovered you know getting
out there is that we've got more in
common
than we have different no matter how we
talk what we dress like or what you know
union or association we belong to or
whatever
people have got more in common than they
have different you know when times are
tough like they have been in this
country
to me it makes more sense to dwell on
what on the good things
that we have in our lives um in order to
get out of the uh
the mire you know it's like well let's
dwell on the good things that we've got
what we might have in common
in order to sort of get out of these
difficult times as opposed to what's
your fault you did this you did that
well you're just those kind of people so
what are you going to do you know
there's finger pointing and nonsense and
just stuck in the same place
so to me it's like you know what we've
got a lot more in common and we have
different we're all in this together
so let's try and get out of it together
by dwelling on the positive
and that's what i think you know we
learnt ourselves
in in this film is that you know we you
see examples of that in the film
and it also really illuminates yourself
because
because like you know uh it shows you it
showed me anyway how much i judge people
and presume them to be a certain type of
person
and then you sit there and go oh i guess
i'm a bit of a numpty then honey because
that just wasn't the case
and that's something that people say a
lot about when they watch the film and
it's you know it's really uplifting and
inspiring as well because you've got
people
in very unexpected places unexpected
times saying these really sort of like
heartening things you look at it you're
like you know what
this thing is all right this country's
alright with these people
with this american spirit intact like it
is
people will learn it's a young country
and people will learn from these
experiences we all learn from
experiences good or bad
and that's what the country's doing now
and that's what the people of this in
the film
show us you know and you walk away going
like i think it's going to be all right
you know you're like oh great you know
and it's the people of the film that
are interviewees that show us that
and i see from your website that you
said that you had never really done
interviews before and so you googled how
to interview people which i thought was
great what did you find out and also
you took psychology in school yeah i
studied psychology of acting
spiritual psychology of acting so that
was that
yeah um well it was very strange because
the only person that i had interviewed
ever prior to this film
was in fact the dalai lama which was
just a bit strange to have that on the
resume for a one-time interview
so um and that's because i was involved
in a documentary uh with some people
um and uh john sally the basketball
player and gustavo santoleo the the
the music composer and myself were sort
of chronicled
on a journey across india through
various sort of religious um
um uh
places we were in you know hindu country
we were in sikh country we were in
muslim country you know and
um it culminated with meeting the dalai
lama and being able to ask him a few
questions
and so that's the only person i'd
interviewed before
and uh and i say interviews two
questions but
um this was six months later we're
thinking well now we're going to sort of
you know
travel across america and ask lots of
questions and i just remember
i think i remember the one thing that
stuck in my mind was how do you feel
about
you know so how do you feel about the
state of the country at the moment not
like what do you think of this or what
do you think of this
there was something about and then and
it was the how do you feel or or what
makes you feel that way
i just remember hanging on to those
words uh in terms of interviewing
i just remember the google and that how
do you feel about what makes you feel
that way okay
remember that remember that but
regardless of whatever i may or may not
have discovered on
googling uh the interviewing technique
the one thing that was important to me
at that time was i didn't want to go in
there with my own agenda
i didn't want to be sitting there you
know no matter who i am
wanting to sort of put my whole
agenda on to well what i feel about the
country
and how i think people are thinking i
just want to be like okay so you're an
nra member
okay um so how do you feel about you
know the state of things how do you feel
about blah blah blah
and just no matter what people said no
matter how
uplifting or inspiring or or subversive
or controversial it might have been just
to be like okay so you
feel that way um
what makes you feel that way you know
how do we what what do you um what do
you take from that and
and you know just being open and
receptive and not trying to put too much
of my
stuff onto it and at times that was a
bit challenging
but ultimately much more interesting
because i can sit with myself i know
what i think all day long i could sit
wherever i want
sit and talk about what i think terribly
boring
but much more interesting to find out oh
gosh so you think that way
why is that then i just keep people just
keep opening them up you know and then
then we had some interesting interviews
it's almost like being a therapist
in some ways oh i don't know if i'd make
a very good therapist but um
it's um it was certainly you know people
do like to talk and all we did on those
because it
obviously was a bit strange i guess in
the middle of arkansas an australian in
an englishman
uh you know rolling up and going excuse
me we're making this interview we're
making this documentary about you know
america
well here you boy where you come from
you know i don't know what you do
but i found that you know if you just
look people in the eye
and just say to them what it is you're
doing and that'd be lovely to talk to
you
you know people are okay and then you
just initially asked somebody how's life
around here
and um you know people become quite open
for a good chit chat
so that's what we found which interview
was the most surprising to you i mean i
have many favorites of the ones that i
saw but
which one really blew you away in terms
of
what was said the the mindset well i
think the nra
gentleman uh kyle is the one that you
know still gets me
and and seems to have an effect on other
people because there we are outside a
gun show
with a guy big guy you know with his gun
on his side and his nra hat on and
everything
and you're thinking oh god here we go
the gun show thing you know
and this guy was amazing he was an
environmentalist
like one of his lines is yeah you don't
need to sling lead down a range to get
your point across sit down buckle up
have a coffee you know what do
politicians really know about places
they're trying to take over an effect in
the world you know
be a bit more um open to other cultures
and
you know it was like some lefty
tree-hugging liberal sitting there
but he wasn't necessarily one or the
other he was just
present and just thinking well why do we
do this and you don't need to sling lead
down a range it's that and it wasn't
necessarily that he was one thing or
another
to be labeled he was just this guy just
making sense and and just
being kind of logical i guess and
but you know exposed the way that we
approach those situations we're going oh
here we go nra gun show but then this
guy going well no if you've got
sun and solar and you can use the sun's
energy to
kind of uh bring some light
for the night then that kind of makes
sense doesn't it just use the daytime
solar bit to look after the night bit
and you're like
yeah i guess that makes sense then you
don't have to go and trounce around and
do the oil stuff in kind of places that
we shouldn't really be
in and that's just what he was saying
and it seemed to make sense what he was
saying you know
so he was he was just you know uh he was
fascinating
but who are your favorites what stuck
out for you for me i think the teacher
was one of my favorites kevin the
teacher in louisville the one who who
said that he has the kids start with a
mantra before he
opens the class of i'm not my
neighborhood i'm not my mother and i'm
not my father
yeah and actually that ties into one of
the questions because he talks about
america being a land of opportunity
but he says sometimes some opportunities
are swayed more
in favor toward others than than some of
the children that he was dealing with
yeah
what are your thoughts on that i mean do
you feel that the way things are now
it's almost similar to the british class
system where there's
less mobility you know okay
there are clearly um more privileged
situations
into which one can be born
or or find yourself living in and
clearly
there is um more opportunity for
others according to those things those
aspects
however personally
i i mean look uh you know my dad's not
kenneth branagh and my mum's not emma
thompson and i'm an actor you know and
i'm sort of
doing all right in these hollywood hills
and stuff and
my dad was a chef and my mum was a
secretary basically
and lived in little small towns in
england at the end of the cul-de-sac
with
you know tupperware parties happening in
1977 thinking
is this it does it okay interesting
um um and um
i think it's easy
um for us at any time to sort of rest
in a story that we create as individuals
or
as a neighborhood or as a city or as a
society or a country or whatever
and just say well this is my life and so
it's not fair for me
and you know it's all right for those
people on the other side of the tracks
and
i think i mean every day is a bit of a
miracle isn't it and i just think that
if we think more about what is possible
and we spend more time thinking about
what we have therefore
and then be grateful about that and
therefore create a more positive sort of
energy about ourselves because we're
like oh i've got my arms and legs that's
fantastic it's pretty good day actually
i haven't got any nasty disease that's
all right you know i wish i had a bigger
this or a better that or more of this
but you know what in the meantime
it's all right i'm quite happy i'm
fortunate i'm breathing i'm living i'm
seeing this whole like miraculous thing
that's happening around me
and then you sort of feel a bit better
and then i think there's a great
propensity for more positive things to
come into your life as a result of just
feeling better
whereas sort of sitting inside a story
and going oh well you know my life's
there so nothing's going to happen to me
and
you know the whole life well i should be
so lucky and all that sort of stuff
you know little declarations and
statements that we say all the time
self-limitation you know you look at
that and you think well
now that's going to happen because
you're thinking it and that's your
vibration now you know i don't only get
two
stars and moons about it but i do think
that what you
you you create what you think is kind of
what you create because you're thinking
it so you're like well nothing's gonna
happen nothing good's gonna wrap around
here mate
right well that's that then nothing good
is gonna happen around here
anything good can happen anywhere you
know we tell ourselves that you know
nothing good's gonna happen around here
but it does happen
good things do happen and you know
when kevin the teacher talks about you
know some there's more opportunity for
others than there are
for others yeah sure there there are you
could be born into certain situations
where that can be the case but there's
no reason why
you know you can't just step outside of
the story that's going on around you
whether it's in your
in your mind or in your family or in
your neighborhood
your city and just go you know what i'm
stepping out of this
there's something better miracles happen
every day and i'm gonna be one of them
you know and um i remember a very
successful basketball player saying
something like that to me once he said
he just looked around and went you know
what i'm not doing this
i'm not i'm i'm stepping outside of this
story
and he became very successful and um
i believe that if you believe it
anything can happen but in the but in
the meantime
just think to yourself well you know
what it's all right in the meantime and
have got me hands behind whatever makes
me happy
is is going on i've got that so thank
you
cheers appreciate it very much but i
wouldn't mind a bit of that life would
be nice if i could have a bit of that i
could be a service as well
and then you do that and then um you
feel better
and then you might make a few other
people feel better as well along the way
so
you know anything's possible isn't it if
you want it to be
one other interview that i thought was
god did i sound like billy graham or
something was that a bit much
no no no i get it because a lot of times
i i was reading something on quora the
other day that so much bad stuff happens
sometimes
when you're on a downturn and then you
add alcohol to that whole thing and then
the whole thing blows up and people were
talking about losing their jobs
and how it was like a spiral of
negativity and and i do see that it's
just hard to see it when you're in that
moment i
i get it it is hard to see it you know
and i'm not saying it's easy to just
sort of go
no i i i hear what you're saying i know
when i first came to los angeles people
oh it's very difficult it's very
competitive and all the rest of it and i
was thinking well
i just happened to be here because of
circumstance
i was like well you know yeah okay it's
competitive and difficult and what have
you
of course but anyway i'm here now so
should we you know
let's see what we can go on oh is that
beverly hills you know just enjoy the
experience you know i mean just
there's always something good to
experience around you you know it's
always something good somewhere
let's just look at that how do you feel
about
hollywood after making this documentary
um
hollywood is this place where stories
are told
right and we all love to hear stories
we've been doing it since we came in
sitting around you know the campfire and
you know exchanging stories and you know
they're they're designed to
to learn from raise our consciousness
you know um
to learn from and um
hollywood's a place where they tell
those stories on whatever scale or other
you know
um and
i personally find that if i'm involved
in any of those stories as an actor
which i find myself being um
you know that's wonderful opportunity
and a chance to play and
you know enjoy and and hopefully serve
that script serve that character
as best i can but for me i find that you
know journeys like
uh this american journey with the
documentary
you know that's when i really sort of
see humanity you know i mean whether
it's american
humanity or if i go to india and i see
indian people living in a certain way or
africa or china or any of these places
and i personally like to get out there
where you know
everyday sort of folks are living in
everyday ways
um and
also finding a lot more happiness than
one might sort of think exists in you
know
poor places i remember going to mali
once which is the third poorest place in
the world and i've never seen some
smiley happy faces you can walk around
beverly hills and then you can
wait all day for somebody to smile you
know and there's a
there's a difference going on there um
without criticizing any situation or
other
but you know one can't help but notice
these things and i just find that the
more i travel around
um and the more people that i'm exposed
to
the more humanity i'm exposed to so if
i'm going to be popped into
you know placed into one of these
hollywood stories or tv shows or films
or whatever
then if i've experienced a bit more
humanity from some far-flung places then
maybe i'm a little bit more
uh better equipped to to uh portray that
character in some way or other
you know um i would
hope so and so for me it's um
it's important you know not just to sort
of stay in little bubbles
you know in hollywood or you know
manhattan or
or london or whatever it's important for
me personally to sort of get out there
and see what's going on in the world
and then when all these stories in
hollywood are told you're like oh yeah i
saw something like that one so
yeah i can bring that into it now and
hopefully do a slightly better job
you